yes we are indeed with sam shanklin
first of all sam tell us how do you feel
going into the playoffs i think probably
he's favorites but not a huge one i'm
not a great rapid player but
i'm not totally hopeless
he's the small favorites but
i wouldn't give him more than 60 and
you know i think if i play reasonably
well i'll have my chances tell us a
little bit about today's game how did
you approach and did you feel like
you're getting on edge at any point yeah
i mean i
i sort of did the same strategy as us
championship which was play something
sort of fresh and non-forcing and not
wildly threatening but just sort of let
him burn all his time and where he has
to figure out how to put the pieces and
i do think white got a nice edge at some
point where i was um
but i guess i misplayed it after he
played rook b5 the only like when i
played bishop a4 it i think it just
forces down this bishop end game and
he's just barely in time to save it by
one tempo were you surprised by that 35
minute thing that he took
oh pleasant i mean not wildly surprised
i thought if i'm going to beat him it's
because he's going to burn all of his
time in some
non-forced position but uh
yeah it's much like we got at the us
championship the only difference is
today i hopefully didn't play like
complete idiots but uh no i thought this
rook this bishop end game he's just
saving it by one tempo which is a real
bomber otherwise he'd be basically dead
if he had to play rook b6 it'd be bad
news and
and if he had to play rook b6 i mean
instead of rook takes c5 i think it
would be very bad news for black after
queen d3 just can't move and
sooner or later rook c4 queen d6 that
should break through um
but uh
but yeah after i think the bishop ending
he's just saving it by one tempo if i'm
not mistaken um
which is a shame but what can you do
you have some time right now before uh
the tie breaks are you going to go
prepare are you going to go grab some
lunch what are you doing i'll prepare a
little bit but mostly i just want to
make sure that i uh
well nourished i realized that i came to
the game today i
forgot both my banana and protein bar so
i was actually really kicking myself for
that and uh hopefully lack of protein
wasn't what uh
let me be unable to win this game well
go get your banana and we'll see you in
a few thank you thank you sam absolutely
thrilling matches that we'll have coming
up for you